in kiev means that i can announce today
that we will very shortly uh next week
reopen our embassy in ukraine's capital
city
i want to pay
tribute to those british diplomats who
remained elsewhere in the region
throughout this period
the
united kingdom and our allies
will not watch passively as
putin carries on
this onslaught and
what i think we've seen
here in
new delhi is
one of the world's oldest democracies
and
the world's largest democracy
sticking together
and
confronting our shared anxieties about
autocracies and autocratic coercion
around the world
and acting together to make our country
safer and more
prosperous our new and expanded defense
and security partnership
will enable
india to strengthen its own domestic
defense industry as well as protecting
vital shared interests in the
indo-pacific
our collaboration on energy security
including our new offer on offshore wind
the new uk india hydrogen
science and innovation hub
and our joint work on solar power
i will help to reduce
our collective dependence on imported
hydrocarbons in favor of cheaper and
more sustainable homegrown renewables
and our global innovation partnership
will help transfer climate and energy
smart innovations to developing
countries around the wider indo-pacific
as we deepen the partnership between our
countries we won't just make our people
safer
we'll make them more prosperous as well
creating new jobs
driving up wages and driving down prices
for consumers all of which helps with
the cost of living
and
our partnership with
india is particularly powerful in
achieving these things because
india
is
an incredible rising power in asia one
of the fastest growing economies in the
world already worth
2.25 trillion pounds and set to be the
world's third largest the world's third
largest economy by 2050. india
is also our biggest partner in the
indo-pacific which is increasingly the
geopolitical center of the world with
two-thirds of humanity and a third of
the global economy and that share is
rising every year
indian investment already supports
almost half a million british jobs
and with a population bigger than the us
and the eu combined there is so much
potential for us to take our trade and
investment to a whole new level
on this visit alone we've secured
new deals
worth a billion pounds creating more
than 11 000 jobs
and perhaps most significantly of all
we're using our brexit freedoms to reach
a bilateral free trade agreement and
today prime minister modi and i told our
negotiators to get it done by diwali in
october
this could double our trade and
investment by the end of the decade
driving down prices for consumers and
increasing wages across the uk by as
much as 3 billion pounds so what we're
getting on with here is uh delivering on
the priorities of the british people but
also
deepening a friendship with a nation
with whom we have profound ties of
language culture and kinship while
making both our countries safer and our
economies stronger
we're going to take a few questions from
the
media and
we have uh we're going to go first to
some uk journalists and then uh to uh
some of our our indian colleagues so
first of all
can i go to ben wright of the bbc
thank you thank you prime minister
in your discussions about ukraine did
you ask prime minister modi to use his
influence in moscow to put pressure
on russia and did you get any sense that
he would do that
and
on trade you said there'll be a free
trade agreement uh with india by diwali
but considering the number of party
investigations uh going on back home are
you absolutely sure you'll still be
prime minister then uh okay the second
answer is yes uh but on the um
on your on your your point about um
[Music]
ukraine and and the indian perspective
look i mean i think you have to
recognize that
the
uh
the
indians have actually in uh and uh
narendra modi in particular have have
come out and uh been very strong in
their language about what's happened in
uh in butcher and talking to
narendra prime minister modi today it's
it's clear that he has already
intervened several times uh and i'm sure
this is no secret from uh our indian
friends he's intervened several times
with uh with vladimir putin really to
ask him what you know what on earth he
thinks he's doing
and and where he thinks this is going
and what the indians want is is peace
and they want uh the russians out
and uh i
totally agree with that and i think that
you know there's a there's a difference
in the
uh in the balance
clearly because
india has a historic relationship with
uh with russia which everybody
understands and respects that goes back
that goes back decades but you know what
was so interesting about the last couple
of days has been the way in which
uh
britain and india
are being
really uh encouraged
obliged by the pressure of events
today
as i say autocratic coercion uh whether
it's in
russia or china or wherever
to
do more together and and that is and
that is i think a
uh offering up a huge huge joint agenda
and there are three three big areas
where you're seeing
uh work being done now they're on the
green growth side
big big agenda for us uh clean power
and a lot of work is being done on that
they're on the security and defense side
and a a huge amount there which i i
could i could go into and then of course
on the on the trade agreement and there
i think yeah you know all trade
agreements are tricky ben to get to your
your point about trade but
um
and there will be there will be tough
asks of both sides
but i'm sure we can do it and what you
got today was a massive push
in the
from the from both governments to get it
done and so i'm i'm very i'm very very
encouraged
anushka astana itv
thank you
prime minister um
you say that
mr mogi
has asked vladimir putin what on earth
he's doing
but
we know that india has now stayed on key
motions at the u.n over this its foreign
secretary has just come out and said you
didn't put any pressure on india to
change its position why isn't that what
did the prime minister say that
convinced you more questions not
necessarily just normal questions you're
facing three investigations back home
and it's led to a catastrophic loss
in trust holding this week from you girl
says that 74 of the british public think
you're untrustworthy only 12
think you're trustworthy some say you're
like a cat with nine lives how many have
you got left
um well uh anushka on your on your
second question uh you know we had a
talking about cats we had a you know
pretty good uh kick of the cat uh
yesterday uh i i'm not that in favor of
kicking cats for avoidance of diet uh
but um you know we did all that we great
respect and uh what we're what we're
talking about today as i said in my
answer to
to ben is uh the the ways in which the
the situation not just in ukraine the
situation around the world is obliging
the uk and india to do more together and
uh the
the position on your your position on uh
russia that the indians have
historically is is well known
uh they are not going to to change that
of course that's true uh but they are
you know they can see what is going on
and uh there is
an increasing appetite to do more with
the uk and if you look at what uh justin
just in the security and defense uh side
of it uh
on uh a maritime propulsion electric
maritime propulsion of of of ships on
new uh
on new aero engines on
uh
on undersea
capabilities uh on
on cyber
helicopters space
a huge new
joint agenda
and that is being driven by contemporary
events and i think it's a it's a
a positive thing it's a it's a it's a
great opportunity and it's fully and
what it does is it helps to to drive the
uh the make in india agenda
uh of uh prime minister modi
uh but also helped to to drive the idea
of of co-production
and and doing things together
and that's where i think the opportunity
is hugo hugo guy the eye
thank you prime minister you've made it
clear you don't want to talk about uh
questions over your future and and over
your conduct but
it's also clear that voters are
interested in this polls have repeatedly
showed that voters are deeply concerned
uh about
um
about downing street parties and about
your position what what's your message
to the british public
are they wrong to care about these
things
um and and can i ask you you've talked
about your friendship with narendra modi
and the close relationship
um that you've struck
during your conversations did you bring
up uh the concerns from human rights
groups that he's presided over a culture
of growing hindu nationalism and
democratic black sliding in india
so we we always have uh so on your first
uh point hugo look i think that uh what
people want in uh in our country is for
the government to get on and focus on
the issues on which we were elected
and that's what we're going to do and i
think they'll be particularly
interested in uh
jobs growth in the uk
uh
a
memorandum of understanding for instance
today
on on wind power gigantic ambitions for
uh more more wind energy uh both of us
from offshore wind offshore and not just
offshore but floating platforms we want
to uh to work on together uh to produce
substantial quantities of of new wind
power which will enable us to produce
more energy for our people together in a
very short time that strikes me as being
a reasonable thing uh for the government
of the uk uh to focus on that is what we
are uh focused on with greatest respect
to uh to you know the evidence that you
uh you may cite and uh secondly um on
the
our relations with india and you know
how we uh how we deal with with uh
questions about human rights or
democratic values of course we have
these conversations but they the the the
advantage of our uh of our friendship is
we can have them and we can have them in
a friendly and uh and private way and i
just i just want to say on on
you know it is very important to realize
india has constitutional
uh protections uh for communities uh
they're part of its its constitution uh
india uh is a very very different
country from uh
autocracies around the world it is it is
a great great democracy and that's why
and and you know that it is a
stunning shining fact 1.35 billion
people who live under a democracy and
that's something we should celebrate and
it offers us a an opportunity for uh for
closer cooperation and partnership that
doesn't mean i'm not going to raise uh
tough consular questions as as i have
today uh and other difficult questions
of course we do that but we do that as
friends okay mesa hall the express
thank you very much
could i ask you to say a bit more about
your discussions on a free trade deal
and what that means in terms of widening
visa access to the uk from india
does that mean a relaxation of your
point of view immigration policy and can
you explain or how would you explain to
brexit voters that you've identified
gaps in the labour market but in this
instance you're looking to fill them
through immigration rather than
encouraging firms to raise skills and
raise wages
yeah thanks very much mata i i think the
first the first challenge we have of
course is to raise
uh skills and raise expectations in our
in our own country get people into into
the jobs that that that we have we've
currently got about 500 000 uh jobs that
aren't filled possibly well actually
1.25 million vacancies
we have uh 1.8 million people
unemployed what i want to see is a lot
of those people who are currently on the
unemployment register off benefits and
into work and that's why we set out the
way to work challenge earlier this year
to get half a million uh off benefits
and and into work that's making uh
that's making progress i want to see
people get the skills that they need to
do the jobs that the the uk
uh has begging to be done and there are
there are many many of them
in all in lots of sectors but we have
some particular shortages and uh if you
look for instance at
it
uh you look at uh computer programming
there are areas where there's no
question that indian skills can make a
difference so you're right mater and
your in your priorities
i'm going to prioritize skilling up the
british people to do those jobs but i'm
not going to be uh dogmatic in refusing
to allow people with skill and talent uh
to aspire to come to the uk
and our country has done brilliantly
well uh from having people of ambition
and skill a genius coming to to to our
uh to the uk and uh all i would say is
that we need to control it
and that's what we we're doing so it in
no way changes just to get to your point
about the points based system in no way
changes the the advantages of the poi
points based system on the contrary the
points based system now gives us the
ability to decide
which sectors need
which types of of workers
and uh how we how we can deal with uh
immediate shortages and that's what
we're going to do
thank you uh did you have another
question that was it that was it thanks
uh hey though
heather stewart the guardian
um a new report from the royal united
services institute today says russia is
laundering components for weapons from
western countries including the uk
through india you've announced an open
export licence for defence on this visit
how will you ensure nothing that we
export to india ends up in vladimir
putin's hands and second one if i may
are you going to pass legislation
allowing the government to suspend
aspects of the northern ireland protocol
thanks very much uh heather so look we
do we one of the things that have been
really effective in the in the sanctions
that we've seen so far is the ban on
tech transfer to to russia and that
really makes a a difference and uh it's
it's starting to mean that you know they
can't service their their planes uh
their their their real problems starting
to arise we've got to ensure we keep
that uh band tight uh we'll be making
sure that we uh don't allow any
loopholes of any kind uh and on and and
so we we won't uh we will take steps to
make sure that stuff does not uh go
through other uh other routes to uh to
to russia on on your on your point about
uh the northern ireland protocol look
this is this is something that um has
been a
consistent uh issue for
uh for the uk government and i think the
it's very very simple it's the it's it's
it's about the the balance of the good
friday agreement and
uh because of what is happening uh i
think that be fair to say that the the
protocol really does not command the
confidence of a of a large large
component of
uh the the population in in northern
ireland we we have to address that we
have to fix that uh the very substantial
diversions of of trade and it's going on
and it's in it's getting uh more acute
we have to fix that we and uh we can we
think we can do it with some very simple
and reasonable steps
and uh we've talked repeatedly to
uh our friends and partners in the in
the eu will continue to to talk to them
but as i've said many times now we don't
rule out uh taking further steps uh if
that's necessary and
and that's the that's the position but
i've said that many times uh
of course of course uh
steve that goes to that thing uh steve
swim for the times
thank you um prime minister western
intelligence officials briefed us
yesterday that the war in ukraine could
continue until the end of next year and
they say bluntly that russia could win
that is a scenario that's possible do
you accept that assessment particularly
that time frame and secondly you're
reopening our embassy in kiev can we
expect regular visits by you and other
ministers in coming months so steve yes
i mean look i think the the
the sad thing is that
that is a realistic possibility yeah of
course uh putin has a a huge army uh he
has a very difficult political position
because he's made a catastrophic blunder
he has the the only option he now has
really is to continue to try to use his
of his appalling grinding approach
driven led by uh by artillery uh trying
to grind the ukrainians down and
he's very close to securing a land
bridge in uh in mario paul now uh
you know the the situation is is i'm
afraid unpredictable at this stage we
just got to be realistic about that but
what we've also seen is the incredible
heroism of the ukrainians and their
willingness to fight and i tell you
something i think that no matter what
military superiority vladimir putin may
be able to bring to bear in the next
few months and i agree it could be it
could be a long period he will not be
able to conquer the spirit of the
ukrainian people that is just an
observable fact
on the contrary what he's doing every
day
is strengthening and reinforcing that
will to resist in the people of ukraine
and so i think what the what we in the
in the
supporters of the ukrainian people need
to think about is what we what further
steps we can do
to uh support them military and
you know about what we're doing with uh
the artillery that we're sending the the
shells that we're sending both nato uh
standard and uh uh and warsaw pact a
former warsaw pact uh standard you know
about the uh the armored cars 150
armored cars
i think that's what i haven't said in
public before is that we're we're also
looking more at what we can do to
backfill in uh in countries such as
poland who may want to send a heavier uh
weaponry to defend uh the help defend
the the ukrainians so we're looking at
uh at sending tanks to uh to poland uh
to to to to help them as they as they
send some of their t-72s uh to uh to
ukraine uh at
other steps uh like that uh and you know
i think about the
uh the anti-ship uh defenses and
and so on so we've got to look at the
uh what more we can do militarily we've
got to keep intensifying the economic
sanctions
and that's what we're doing whatever we
want to make sure that there are there
is wave after wave of intensifying
pressure
on on putin and we've also got to set
out
a vision for the future of ukraine in
the security architecture of
of europe and you know where does
ukraine fit in now because that i think
is a question that everybody
will need to answer the ukrainians will
need to be able to answer that question
uh if and when there is ever a realistic
negotiation which doesn't seem likely at
the present time but eventually
what the ukrainians want and i think i'm
now going to get
is a
collection of security guarantees uh
from like-minded countries security
commitments about what we can do to back
them up
with uh with weaponry with training and
uh with
intelligence sharing
not like an article five guarantee won't
be exactly the same thing but what it
will be do i hope
it will be enable the
ukrainians to offer
deterrence by denial
and to make sure that their territories
is so fortified as to be impregnable in
the future to to further attack from
from russia that's that's what we need
uh what we need to do and on your
question about
getting uh ministers to to keep i'm all
in favor of that uh but you know i we
have no we have no immediate immediate
uh announcements uh i think it's a good
thing if if people uh do go there to
show their uh their support their
solidarity uh with the with the
ukrainian government and with with
vladimir zolensky uh
thanks i think that was both things
uh can i go to camel jit sandhu from
india today
so my question is sorry uh india has
several concerns as far as nirv modi and
vijay malia are concerned
how is uk taking those up also uh there
is also an issue about kalistani
extremist
there has been a concern from the indian
side for quite some time what actions
have been taken yeah thank you very much
uh kamajit so you won't surprise you to
learn that both these things were raised
uh with us and
we have a
a very strong view in the uk that we we
we don't tolerate uh extremist groups uh
setting up uh in the uk with a view to
causing um
uh
threatening uh other countries uh
threatening india uh but what we've done
in particular as a result of this visit
is set up a an anti-extremist uh task
force to see what more we can do to uh
help india uh in that particular respect
and
on the the two individuals that you
mentioned for the extradition cases
i think
um
there are legal technicalities that uh
have made it very very difficult but
what i can tell you
is that the
uh the uk government has ordered their
uh their extradition and that we have
said that from our point of view we want
them uh to be uh taken back to it to
india uh for trial and
perhaps i should just say you know
perhaps going back to mesa's point uh we
you know we we welcome uh people who uh
who have talent and and brilliance
coming from india to to the uk we you
know we don't we don't welcome i want to
make it absolutely clear now uh we don't
welcome people who want to use
our legal system to evade the uh evade
the law here in india so let me be
absolutely absolutely absolutely clear
about that let's go to uh
hassan laskar from his hindustan times
mr prime minister you spoke here sorry
uh you spoke both yesterday and today
about the ambitions for having the free
trade agreement by october yes uh what
if any other sticking points or the
tough asks that are you know that you
need to surround before october and
secondly if i may uh the expanded
defense partnership
india and the uk haven't had a major
defense deal since 2003 when the deal
for the hawk aircraft was signed
and now india has moved towards
manufacturing most of the defense
equipment within the country how are you
going to work with india on this on this
aspect is it going to be technology
transfers or you know boosting indian
project production production thank you
thanks very much uh results so look
there are
there are several several things uh
there first of all the
the free trade
deal i think there are going to be some
difficult issues uh tariffs uh
you know
uh tariffs on on on whiskey uh is a is a
tough one uh would be a great thing i
think if if we could if we could if we
could fix that but you know there are uh
there are all sorts of
uh of things that need to be
uh addressed i think that but there are
big big opportunities and we can get it
done and the the firm message has gone
out from uh from our friends uh to to to
to make progress and so i'm you know i'm
optimistic
and
on on your point about defense and and
how that's gonna and how that's gonna
work look you're entirely right what
we've agreed is that there has to be a
focus
on a company to company basis and and so
when we look at these uh some of these
projects that i've described whether
it's uh electric propulsion for the
ships or or new area aero engines for uh
for fighters or or undersea technology
or or whatever it happens to be uh what
we're going to do is make sure that we
bring our companies uh together
uh and there are some great companies uh
in india uh but that we that we have an
approach of of co-production joint
development
and and doing it that way so it
satisfies the maiden made in the making
india uh objective but also uh works in
terms of uh in terms of technology
transfer and what we what we agreed at
this
uh at this meeting is that our national
security advisors our defense ministers
uh our foreign ministers uh will now get
together in a rolling uh program so that
we make
progress on this uh within uh within a
year uh but there is a there is a a big
agenda of work already underway so
that's it folks i think that's the i
think i've i have now addressed my
budget of questions i just want to i
just want to remind you uh in case you
in case you've forgotten the key
statistics and takeouts from this uh
from this
uh wonderful
mission and visit to india uh one
billion pounds of investment in the uk
eleven thousand jobs i i would i i hope
that that hasn't escaped you uh
how many times when i said that uh an
mou on uh on wind um
uh green hydrogen uh uh working together
on solar energy uh
cooperation on uh small monuments from
modular reactors the whole security and
defense partnership that we've just uh
discussed new partnerships with uh
universities and new partnerships on uh
on medicine including new work on
malaria vaccines uh to follow up on the
groundbreaking work that the uk and
india did for instance over the uh
oxford astrazeneca vaccine of which i am
personally uh the beneficiary i don't
know how many others are in this room
thank you all very much see you soon
thank you
the prime minister they're concluding
his press conference in new delhi as he
concludes his two-day
visit there to negotiate a trade deal
with the indian prime minister narendra
modi concluding the press conference
with what he wanted to talk about of
course that
those trade negotiations but of course
in the uh line of questioning from the
journalists particularly the uk
journalists he was uh being drawn on a
number of different issues uh including
and notably the war in ukraine where he
said uh that he thought that there was a
realistic possibility that russia could
win that war uh putin has a huge army he
said he did confirm that in support of
ukraine that the uk would be reopening
its embassy in the capital uh next
month also uh in response to one of the
questions said that the uk was looking
to send tanks
to poland so that they could then send
them to
ukraine on the stickier matter for him
of
partygate he was keen to deflect those
questions but said simply that he was
confident that he would remain
prime minister where we can get some
reaction now from our deputy political
editor
sam coates who is uh live
in westminster for us uh hello there sam
uh well knock me down with a feather not
many of the uk journalists wanted to
talk to him did they about the ins and
outs of those trade negotiations or the
11 000 jobs no it's pretty much as you
just listed sam uh he wanted to talk
about the fact that they'll be
re-opening the embassy in kiev uh that
he's saying for the first time that
they're gonna backfill the armaments
that have gone from countries like
poland uh to ukraine by giving tanks to
poland he lined into the idea that we
could accept more migrants from india
the statistics out last week show that
india is actually one of the big
beneficiaries of brexit we've changed
the way
that we do uh migration in this country
and uh that has meant that many more
indians have come into this country he
seemed to be suggesting that press
conference there'll be a bit more of
that he said a trade deal by diwali
citing whiskey tariffs it's one of the
more complicated issues
and he even suggested that he could end
up ripping up the trade treating over
northern ireland that would come after
the northern ireland elections at the
start of may we'll see what happens with
that but you do have all of the domestic
issues that he's going to be flying back
into unhappiness all across the
conservative party another conservative
mp uh today coming out saying that he's
going to take appropriate action because
he's unhappy with what's happening with
partygate when pressed on that by
journalists uh boris johnson insisted he
would still be promised by october and
said that we'd had a pretty good goal in
his words we kicked the cat on that
yesterday not really wishing to be drawn
on it
all right sam uh thank you
meanwhile the russian military has said
that it plans to take full control of
ukraine's disputed donbass region as
well as the south of the country as part
of what it calls the second phase of its
military operation well let's look at
today's other key developments in the
war a united nations mission to the kiev
suburb of busha has documented the
unlawful killing including by summary
execution of some 50 civilians
the ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky has confirmed reports that
russia has rejected a proposal for an
easter humanitarian
break
boris johnson has just announced that
britain will reopen its embassy in the
capital thanks to the extraordinary
fortitude and success of ukraine in
resisting russian forces and the world
bank says that it would cost a
staggering 60 billion dollars to restore
all the buildings and infrastructure
that have been damaged in ukraine during
this war
well our correspondent mark stone has
all the latest on this now from zaparica
we've just had some remarkable uh
remarkably open information from moscow
on what they believe phase two of their
invasion or their limited military
operation as they call it will look like
they have said that once they capture
the donbass this large area in the far
east of ukraine that will give them a
land bridge to crimea
they say that they will encircle